You're in good shape.
Thank you.
You work out hard.
Yeah.
You do, and I've noticed this before,
cause I I've checked you out.
All right.
How many sit-ups do you do a day?
A day?
Yeah.
Roughly, probably a
thousand. A thousand sit-ups.
You do a thousand sit-ups?
How many pushups do you do a day?
Push-ups, anywhere between five and 700.
Okay that's, you're very disciplined.
You've got a good physique.
Does your fiance,
beautiful, beautiful woman,
Is she appreciative that you
have such a good physique?
Oh, that's what starts it.
Yeah, that's what keeps you motivated.
See, when you first start
walking out, working out,
your lady starts off and she'll
give you a look like hmm.
Something, hmm. Right?
But it's the, it's the
noise that gets you.
One day you're going to
hear a mmm, like that.
It gets a little deeper and you hear it.
As a man you turn around,
and when she start calling
me her little nugget,
that's when I was like,
I got something going.
Nugget?
Yeah.
She calls you nugget?
Her little nugget.
Nugget?
Where my little nugget at?
Here I go. Here I go. Here I go.
You better get in here a little nugget.
(footsteps tapping)
(audience laughing)
I love that.
Do you find that taller
women are attracted to you?
Yeah. You know, I've
had, back in my heyday,
you know, before I was at
this point in my relationship.
I'm engaged to get married.
So you gotta be careful here.
I'm talking about back in the day.
Back in the day.
Yeah well, you know Conan,
I done chopped a couple
trees down, you know.
You know, they come in tall,
but they leave on the stump.
If you know what I'm talking about.
You're working on a movie with the rock.
Yes.
And, and it was in the summer and you,
I just heard that you
almost knocked him out.
And when I heard it,
I thought, was this like a
fight scene or something?
And how did you almost knock out the rock?
Well, first of all, it
definitely wasn't a fight scene.
Just want to clear that up.
What, what happened was
there was a, we were on set.
We were on stage and I really
almost killed the rock.
So he's chasing me into a room.
And when I run into the
room, I fling the door open.
And when I fling the door
open, he comes in behind me.
But the ceiling fell.
I flew the door so hard.
Cause I'm so strong up top.
When I flew it,
the piece of ceiling fell and hit him
on the head and like crack.
First of all, he should have
been, he should have been out.
This is what he did.
He goes, it hits him, cracks.
He goes, guess someone's got to fix that.
And I'm like what?
What? What?
We actually have this.
Do you have it?
We have this. Let's take a look.
You're gonna see, I'm not lying.
(audience laughing)
That's me laughing.
You were laughing?
Listen, the reason why you don't hear him.
The reason why you don't hear him
say somebody's got to fix it.
That was me taping it on a monitor,
and I posted it on social media.
That's why I was laughing.
I laughed because I was like,
you're too big to grab
your head like this.
(audience laughing)
[Kevin] Nobody thought
the rock would go ahh.